so this isn't legal advice but if you're
gonna steal four billion dollars worth
of bitcoin
maybe keep a low profile and don't
do this
everyone worries too much about what's
proper but not razz no shame that don't
stop her blindly falling rules for fools
yes stealing billions of dollars in
bitcoin is a crime
but those rap videos are crimes against
humanity
[Music]
yes with the development of the internet
and cryptocurrencies so too came the
opportunity for spectacular crime how
spectacular will criming in the dollar
amount of
billions
enter one heather morgan 31 and her
russian-born husband ilya dutch
lichtenstein 34 who have been charged by
the department of justice with trying to
launder an astounding 4.5 billion
dollars in stolen bitcoins this case is
so captivating not just because of the
staggering dollar amounts or what the
doj described as the alleged labyrinth
of cryptocurrency transactions to
launder the stolen funds but what makes
this case so headline grabbing
well the defendants are to put it mildly
a bit out there liechtenstein calls
himself a technology entrepreneur coder
and investor while his wife morgan well
i'll let morgan introduce herself in her
own words i'm many things a rapper an
economist a journalist a writer a ceo
and a dirty dirty dirty dirty husband in
addition to being an irreverent comedic
rapper using the stage name razzle con
yes i am not making that up morgan is
also self-described as quote a serial
entrepreneur because
of course she is
and a former prolific contributor to
forbes magazine she's even dubbed
herself the crocodile of wall street for
some reason so today let's think like a
cyber security lawyer who may or may not
make investment decisions based on dog
memes so we'll dive into the stunning
indictment examine the characters
involved and analyze the implications on
the law and cryptocurrency in general
and determine if this isn't only the
largest money laundering scheme in
history
but also the cringiest all right so
let's start with the indictment and the
weirdos involved back in 2016 hackers
stole 119 754 bitcoins from the bitfinex
cryptocurrency exchange in hong kong
since that hack the value of those
bitcoins has skyrocketed from 72 million
dollars to an astounding 4.5 billion
dollars in 2022. for six years those
monies successfully evaded the grasp of
law enforcement until now on february 8
2022 the justice department announced
the arrest of ilya lichtenstein and
heather morgan from their new york
high-rise apartment in its statement on
the arrest the doj reported having
successfully recovered 80 of the bitcoin
stolen from bitfinex or 3.6 billion
dollars making it the largest financial
seizure in history department officials
also stated that they plan to establish
a court process for victims seeking to
reclaim their stolen bitcoin
lichtenstein and morgan faced up to 20
years in prison for money laundering
charges in addition the pair could
receive an additional sentence of up to
five years for the charge of conspiracy
to defraud the united states now for
those of you who haven't had money
laundering explained to them by saul
goodman your filthy drug money has been
transformed into nice clean taxable
income
brought to you by a savvy investment in
a thriving business
it refers to the act of making large
amounts of money obtained by criminal
activity appear to come from legal
sources and conspiracy to defraud the
united states generally criminalizes the
use of deception to cheat the government
out of property or money or to otherwise
impair obstruct or defeat the lawful
function of the government interestingly
the indictment does not allege that the
pair are the ones who actually stole the
money it only alleges that an unknown
hacker gave them the stolen bitcoin and
that the couple attempted to launder the
billions of dollars in crypto to evade
law enforcement following their initial
court appearance the magistrate judge
ruled that lichtenstein could be
released into home detention on a 5
million bond cosigned by his parents the
bond amount for morgan was set at 3
million but both parties were ordered to
remain in custody until the bail
conditions were met prosecutors opposed
granting the defense bail claiming that
they were significant flight risks
prosecutors argued that just a portion
of the billions of dollars in crypto
that they've stole or tried to launder
could buy a new house or quote buy each
of their parents a private island
prosecutors further warned that
liechtenstein who holds dual citizenship
in the u.s and russia was a particular
flight risk as he could flee to russia
and seek immunity if he were no longer
held in the united states custody
federal district judge beryl howell
agreed with prosecutors and modified the
magistrate's bail order accordingly on
february 14th the judge revoked
lichtenstein's bail and ordered him to
remain in jail pending trial judge
howell said that the government had
deemed that morgan was not as involved
in planning the alleged crimes as her
husband and that lichtenstein was
largely in control of the funds himself
judge howe also considered morgan's
health issues as a factor as she
recently had surgery to remove a lump in
her breast with follow-up doctor's
appointments expected the court released
morgan into house arrest with a gps
ankle monitor now i would be remiss not
to take this opportunity to go into the
story background of dutch and razzlecon
so before delving into the specifics of
the indictment which i should note are
only allegations until proven true in a
court of law as the defendants are
presumed innocent until proven guilty i
want to give a little background on the
couple that the new york times has
dubbed bitcoins bonnie and clyde now
lichtenstein who goes by the nickname
dutch describes himself on his linkedin
page as an angel investor in technology
companies and an advisor to various
startups a twitter account purportedly
in his name posted frequently on
cryptocurrency trends the technology
sector and the evolution of nfts well
dutch seemed to stick to being your
prototypical crypto bro his wife morgan
jumped between being a self-described
serial entrepreneur and in her words a
quote raunchy rapper making surrealist
art
morgan was also a frequent contributor
to forbes magazine publishing more than
55 pieces between july 2017 and
september 2021. morgan also published
articles on a variety of topics ranging
from soul food served at the 2021 met
gala why women are better negotiators
than men and ironically expert tips on
protecting your business from cyber
criminals it's not ironic it's just
coincidental and i mean in fairness
she probably knows more about hacking
bitcoin accounts than most people so
maybe she is an expert in this area now
morgan is also a prolific presence on
tick tock rapping under the name
razzlecon according to her website she's
quote like genghis khan but with more
pizzazz she also characterizes herself
as basically a mix of hunter s thompson
and diane arbus with a sprinkle of tom
green and yeah i mean i guess she's not
completely wrong about that and look
it's easy to make fun but all art is
subjective and it's really not anyone's
place to judge art as good or bad
whoa
razzle dazzle living in a glass castle
don't with no hassle
okay i take it back if the pair is found
guilty i really hope the judge issues an
injunction preventing miss morgan from
ever rapping again and also requests
that miss morgan pay restitution to my
eyes and ears for all the videos i've
watched in preparing for this video
yeah now let's get on to the complaint
itself and on to the whole issue of
laundering billions of dollars in stolen
cryptocurrency now in the statement
announcing the arrest here's how the doj
summarized the defendant's alleged money
laundering scheme the criminal complaint
alleges that liechtenstein and morgan
employed numerous sophisticated
laundering techniques including using
fictitious identities to set up online
accounts utilizing computer programs to
automate the transactions a laundering
technique that allows for many
transactions to take place in a short
period of time depositing the stolen
funds into accounts at a variety of
virtual currency exchanges and dark net
markets basically they would often try
to convert bitcoin into other forms of
virtual currency and other real tangible
assets including anonymity enhanced
virtual currency in a practice known as
chain hopping and using us-based
business accounts to legitimize their
banking activity according to jim lee of
the irs criminal investigation they
conducted a methodical and calculated
scheme to allegedly launder and disguise
their vast fortune and here's how the
government says that they did it in or
around august of 2016 a hacker breached
the bitfinex security system and
infiltrated its infrastructure once in
the network the unidentified hacker was
able to initiate over 2 000 unauthorized
bitcoin transactions resulting in 119
754 bitcoins being transferred from
bitfinex wallets to an unidentified
outside wallet controlled by the
defendants now if you read the actual
complaint you'd be shocked to see how
little of the billions of dollars in
bitcoin was actually laundered and spent
in fact about 80 percent of the nearly
120 000 stolen bitcoin the 3.6 billion
that the government recovered was found
in exactly the same crypto wallet into
which they were originally deposited as
for the remaining 20 well starting in
january of 2017 defendants allegedly
began moving some of the stolen bitcoins
out of the original wallet through a
series of small and complex transactions
across multiple accounts and platforms
now one of those accounts that the
bitcoin was funneled into was the alpha
bay marketplace a prominent dark net
market that was shut down in 2017 by the
fbi working in conjunction with
international law enforcement now the
defendants used a high number of very
small transactions to conceal the path
of the stolen bitcoin and avoid law
enforcement for years so the 3.6 billion
question is how did the defendants get
caught well it was a mix of good
old-fashioned police work due diligence
from the private sector and the public
nature of the blockchain itself oh and
the most helpful element in any
investigation
really stupidly sloppy mistakes from the
alleged criminals because on january
31st 2022 law enforcement gained lawful
access to dutch's cloud storage pursuant
to a search warrant law enforcement
decrypted a single file in dutch's cloud
storage that contained a list of 2 000
virtual currency addresses along with
the corresponding private keys to open
all of those wallets that's not
surprising because one of the most
tedious things about cryptocurrency is
keeping track of all your accounts and
private keys
and that's hard for even people that
have stolen billions of dollars in
crypto coins analyzing the public
blockchain records the feds confirmed
that those addresses came from the 2016
hack because the blockchain is
completely public now in the days that
followed the feds obtained seizure
warrants and used those private keys
contained in dutch's file to seize over
3.6 billion dollars in bitcoin and place
them into the government's possession
also discovered in dutch's cloud a
folder entitled personas that included
biographical info and documents on
numerous individuals a file entitled
passport ideas with links to darknet
sites selling fake passports and a
folder with potential financial
institutions to launder the money which
described alphabank as a quote sketchy
russian oligarch bank
which is definitely not wrong
and not only that but dutch's apartment
also contained a bag labeled burner
phones you know it really makes law
enforcement's job a lot easier when
suspects properly categorize their
crimes and pre-label the evidence ahead
of their arrest it's really considerate
now the private sector aided by
government regulation was also
instrumental in halting some of the
defendant's illegal activities currency
exchanges are regulated by the treasury
department which requires such
institutions to establish anti-money
laundering aml programs and kyc know
your customer protocols to make it
harder for anonymous users to transfer
money in one example of the system
working the defendants allegedly set up
seven alphabay accounts and six from an
established exchange to hold 186
thousand dollars in bitcoin under false
names however following these
verification protocols exchanges were
unable to verify defendant's identities
or prove that they own the accounts so
the accounts were frozen and despite the
setbacks defendants did successfully
launder some of those bitcoins out of
third-party exchanges and according to
the indictment defendants use their
ill-gotten gains to pay for relatively
benign items such as uber rides
hotel.com stays a playstation nfts 500
walmart gift card and even gold but the
defendant's alleged sloppiness which
allegedly bordered on stupidity
continued to hinder their efforts at
money laundering while also at the same
time helping law enforcement to track
them down the gold that dutch purchased
with stolen bitcoin well he purchased it
from an online currency exchange account
which he verified with his real driver's
license which he sent with a selfie
style photograph and he registered that
to his real email address and then dutch
had the gold shipped to his real home
address at the time in san francisco
then again i guess this is exactly what
one might expect from someone who kept
the keys to 3.6 billion dollars in
cryptocurrency in one cloud file
or who married morgan now morgan's less
than genius behavior also raised some
red flags in response to one currency
exchange asking follow-up questions
about the origins of the tens of
thousands of dollars in digital assets
that were to be deposited into
morgan's newly created business account
morgan gave the following not at all
suspicious answer quote my boyfriend now
husband gifted me cryptocurrency over
several years 2014 2015 which have
appreciated i have been keeping them in
cold storage that obviously kg answer is
the money laundering equivalent of my
boyfriend why he goes to a different
school in canada you wouldn't know him
another red flag well the wall street
journal reports that a friend of miss
morgan's noted how she and her husband's
lifestyle did not match their purported
wealth while planning to buy a 2 million
condo in new york the defendants had a
modest wedding and the couple used
airline miles to fly you know just like
the rest of us now maybe the best part
about this entire case is that whether
you are a crypto skeptic or a crypto
booster there's plenty of material for
both camps cryptocritics have often
noted that less than desirable groups
like white supremacists have embraced
crypto as a means of evading law
enforcement and avoiding legal judgments
furthermore in 2021 it marked an
all-time high of 14 billion in
cryptocurrency theft with the innocent
suffering the brunt of the consequences
and of course the bitfinex hack and
subsequent money laundering only
reinforces critics argument that
cryptocurrency is not just ripe for
criminal conduct but is also not nearly
as secure and unhackable as its boosters
claim but at the same time crypto
advocates show that the blockchain
secure technology is working exactly as
intended in the words of crypto boosters
it's further proof that the nature of
the blockchain and
it being always public allows
investigators to follow the money in
ways that would be impossible in complex
webs of shell companies and cash
smugglings that exist with
normal financial tools crypto advocates
argue that the public nature of
blockchain technology not only serves as
self-regulating an anti-fraud measure
but that the global blockchain ledger
allows police to track down the stolen
cryptocurrency in ways that would not be
possible with fiat money bloomberg
columnist matt levine highlights this
inherent contradiction perfectly as
usual saying quote you might think that
a federal criminal indictment for 4.5
billion dollars of bitcoin money
laundering would be vindication of the
bitcoin is for money launderer's side
but i want to tell you no it is not what
allegedly happened here is that hacker
stole 4.5 billion of bitcoin from a
crypto exchange and stealing from
exchanges absolutely is a major function
of crypto and then they had a horrible
time laundering it they managed to
extract only a relatively small portion
of the money for actual spending and
each time they got money out the feds
were able to trace it from the hack all
the way to legitimate accounts with
their names on it matt levine goes on to
analogize if you rob a bank and steal a
sack of money and the bills are
sequentially numbered and a die pack
explodes in the sack and you drive
directly to another bank and hand them a
disdain sack and say i'd like to make a
deposit please you will totally get
arrested and you will probably get
charged with money laundering but in no
meaningful sense did you launder the
money it still has the die on it that's
what happened here and as another crypto
expert said the problem with laundering
cryptocurrency is that if you make a
mistake five years ago that's still on
the blockchain for everyone to see but i
guess one thing that we can all agree is
that whatever your take on
cryptocurrency remember that talking
about it constantly does not make you
cool
now admittedly we've all had our fun
engaging a whole bunch of schadenfreude
over razzlecon and dutch but you know
what goes well with shot and freudia a
nice glass of wine and you can get the
perfect bottle with today's sponsor
brightsellers brightsellers is a
delightful service that helps you find
new fun wines from all over the world it
doesn't matter if you know absolutely
nothing about wine just go to
brightsellers.com and take their seven
question quiz now i like big bold reds
and if we're being pedantic and
obviously we are because this is legal
eagle i like left bank bordeauxs and
cabernets from paso robles but you don't
need to know any of that you just need
to tell them what kind of flavors you
like whether you like reds or whites or
both and tell them how adventurous you
are and they'll do the rest for you
bright sellers will match you with
several great bottles and deliver them
straight to your house you get great
stuff from all over the world and i got
stuff i never would have found on my own
like this falcon fable cabernet from
santa rosa california and this french
misona beam from near bordeaux and i
love that there are wine education cards
included so you learn about what you're
drinking to better articulate what you
like or just fool your wine snob friends
and right now bright cellars is offering
viewers 50 off their first box that's
six bottles of wine for only 53 that's
crazy value and you're guaranteed to
love what you get just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down below
in the description to take the quiz you
get half off your first box and you'll
be supporting this channel or you can
click on this playlist over here for the
rest of my educational-ish videos so
click here or i'll see you in court